[Musique]
vous croyez peut-être qu'on a tout dit
dans les dernières semaines sur la
légalisation du cannabis
on a parlé de l'âge légal ou fumer ne
pas fumer de la conduite sous influence
des études sur les effets du cannabis
sur le cerveau
que cela vous réjouissez
on vous que vous soyez contre les gens
de québec qui le veulent taux de la
marijuana et nous l'ont dit c'est
maintenant chose faite
l'une des promesses électorales phare du
gouvernement de justin trudeau est
devenu réalité nous avons chant avec le
contrôle la réglementation la
légalisation de la marijuana une
question de santé et de sécurité
publique martèle team pour enlever les
profits au crime organisé
on a confié à santé canada le pouvoir de
décider qui peut produire du cannabis
l'une de ses missions c'est d'empêcher
le crime organisé de s'infiltrer dans le
marché légal
lou brouleau éliminer les profits qui
vont aux gangs de rue et aux organismes
criminelle santé canada affirme qu'elle
n'a constaté aucun cas d'infiltration du
crime organisé sur une centaine de
producteurs autorisées mais est ce
vraiment le cas
mais on a documenté plusieurs cas
d'individus qui ont actuellement ou dans
le passé eu des liens importants avec le
crime organisé
ils ont tous pu entrer dans le marché
les gars du cannabis alors on a voulu
savoir quelle était la profondeur des
enquêtes de santé canada de crimes
organisés font des milliards de dollars
sur le laps de temps avec des
marionnettes et c'est exactement ce
pauvre empêcher
[Musique]
nous sommes le 5 juin à quelques mois de
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi pour
légaliser le cannabis ce jour-là à
ottawa claude carignan sénateurs
conservateurs arrivent au parlement il
rejoint ses collègues qui passe en revue
le projet de loi on essaie d'améliorer
pour je vois en proposant des ans maman
qui vont corriger les lacunes qu'on a
identifié
claude carignan s'apprête à proposer à
ses collègues un changement important
projet de loi sur le cannabis
j'ai préparé un amendement qui a pour
objectif d'assurer une plus grande
transparence au niveau des compagnies de
production et également éviter l' usage
de paradis fiscaux pour se cacher dans
les paradis fiscaux
claude carignan est très inquiet de la
légalisation du cannabis parce qu'il a
réalisé qu'avec les contrôles qui
existait dans le cadre du cannabis à des
fins médicales
il n'y avait rien de plus facile pour le
crime organisé que de contour des
enquêtes de santé canada mon objectif à
moi c'est d'éviter que le crime organisé
puisse continuer à âge et dans trafic de
drogue et qui s'en servent par exemple
blanche et d'argent
[Musique]
est ce que on devrait pas interdite et
l'actionnariat étranger des compagnies
de cannabis parce que les doutes du
sénateur carignan se sont cristallisées
au printemps quand des experts sont
venus témoigner devant les sénateurs
par exemple l'avocate et fiscalistes
m'avoir içki avant de faire le saut en
politique au québec est venu leur
expliquer les trous béants dans les
enquêtes de santé canada on ne vérifie
pas un fait qui sont les véritables
bénéficiaires ultimes de ces compagnies
on ne remonte pas jusqu'à la fin de
toutes les structures
parce qu'au canada n'importe qui peut se
cacher derrière des structures opaques
et c'est parfaitement légal alors au
fond ont vu une fille jamais qui sont
les véritables détenteurs des licences
ultime manche
si par exemple nous avons dix
entreprises l'une des tentes qui détient
l'autre de ces l'autre tiens donc
comprenez c'est tous des étages et
utilement à la fin on peut même faire
face à des fiducie les fiducie c'est
l'un des meilleurs moyens de cacher
quelqu'un selon des experts
c'est une entité gérée de cas fait un
peu similaire à une campagne mais qui a
des caractéristiques différentes d'une
copine marie pierre allard et professeur
de droit fiscal à l'université de
sherbrooke les bénéficiaire de la
fiducie ne sont pas révélés publiquement
à c'est à dire que cet anonyme
il n'y a pas moyen de savoir
publiquement qu'ils sont les bénéfices à
la fiducie alors que les actionnaires
d'une compagnie on doit enregistrer
auprès du registraire des entreprises
qui est l'actionnaire majoritaire qui
sont les administrateurs cet anonymat
est un problème sérieux au canada selon
la professeure pas c'est une des unes
des faiblesses - des g vulnérabilité du
système juridique canadien c'est
l'opacité des fiducie justement qui fait
en sorte que c'était 19 ans très
susceptibles d'être utilisés pour des
vaches malades
d'ailleurs nos recherches nous ont
permis d'identifier plusieurs
investisseurs dans les entreprises de
cannabis qui utilisent des fiducie
bonjour honorables sénateurs lors d'une
autre réunion les sénateurs reçoivent
des hauts gradés de la gendarmerie
royale du canada
les gers y explique comment elle assiste
santé canada dans les enquêtes de
sécurité sont les demandeurs de permis
pour les entreprises de cannabis en une
section spécialisée à la grc qui va
faire une recherche de nos dossiers bon
et nous aussi des dossiers à laquelle
est aussi jusqu'à un certain point on a
accès à l'information de d'autres
services policiers travers le pays une
fois que ceux-ci aient fait c'est un
rapport est envoyé à santé canada
puis c'est à eux de prendre la décision
de droit selon les indices qui sont
devant eux
est-ce que c'est con d'émettre un permis
ou pas d'émettre un permis mais claude
carignan et ses collègues ont plusieurs
questions ce que vous avez confiance que
vous êtes vraiment en mesure de voir
derrière les données financières camp de
base qu'on va fournir
est ce que vous allez vous avez
l'intention d'enquêter auprès de ces
entreprises d'eau qui vont
commercialiser du pote légal avec de
l'argent illégal puisque c'est alors que
le surintendant goupil de la grc c'est
un aveu important
il y avait des groupes criminels
organisés qui vont certainement
utilisez les paradis fiscaux ou même
qu'est ce qu'on appelle c'est le
bénéfice on a chip qui vont se cacher
derrière le secret corporation est un
peu pour investir pour aller chercher
des des permis ou des licences pour
trois heures de cannabis nous avons
documenté le cas d'un homme d'affaires
qui a investi dans une très grande
entreprise de cannabis pendant longtemps
il a eu des liens notamment d'affaires
avec des membres de la mafia et grands
trafiquants de drogue
aujourd'hui il gère ses affaires au
moyen de fiducie il y a des limites à ce
que la police peut faire comme enquête
dans le domaine du cannabis légal nous
sommes allés au quartier général de la
grc à avoir rencontré le surintendant
yves goupil beaucoup de réglementation
par rapport aux compagnies qui font que
ces pauvres vraiment facile de savoir
vraiment de ceux qui le propriétaire
réel en arrière de ça aussi qui n'est
vraiment la personne qui est le
bénéficiaire et elle crée des poupées
russes corporatives et des structures
opaques comme ces permis dans notre pays
facilite la vie des organisations tunnel
qui peuvent réinvestir leur argent dans
l'économie légale
c'est très rare qu'ils vont mettre leur
nom aux bonnes de feuilles puis vont
signer et de faire une demande de permis
absolument ils vont soit demander à
quelqu'un d'autre un prête-nom d'ouvrir
une compagnie
ou d'obtenir le permis les autorités
rencontre aussi toute une série
d'obstacles quand l'argent vienne
l'étranger le journal de montréal à
d'ailleurs révélé qu'une trentaine
d'entreprises du cannabis ont bénéficié
de millions provenant des paradis
fiscaux
nous avons tenté de communiquer avec une
obscure compagnie basée à dubaï qui a
investi dans une grande entreprise de
cannabis canadienne pour en savoir
davantage sur l'identité des
investisseurs
personne ne nous a répondu si on veut
éliminer les mafieux du marché du
cannabis mais on ne peut pas leur
permettre d'utiliser les paradis fiscaux
ou des fiducie pour entrer et
indirectement par la porte à narnia dans
le marché donc si l'objectif c'est de
l'étude de tuer ce marché l'eau pour eux
il faut le voir comme il faut et un code
documenté prouve que les fiducie ont
déjà été utilisé dans le passé pour
cacher des gens peu fréquentables
dans les années 2000 l'entreprise ong
médias qui vendait des poubelles à des
villes comme montréal et toronto a nié
avec force avoir délié avec vito rizutto
le parrain de la mafia
il conduisait pourtant une voiture
appartenant à la compagnie puis quand
revenu canada a poursuivi des
actionnaires de la compagnie surprise
plusieurs membres de la famille rizutto
étaient bien cachés comme bénéficiaire
d'une fiducie qui possédait une partie
des actions de l'entreprise
c'est pas tout le monde qui ont défini
six cd clemens entendre mais si
quelqu'un veut utiliser ces outils là
pour avoir des fins illégitimes peu fade
et des fins criminelles
on lui sert sur un plateau d'argent
le canada est un pays qui a des lacunes
en matière de lutte contre le
blanchiment d'argent notamment parce
qu'il permet dé fiducie sans registre
public pour identifier les propriétaires
le groupe d'action financière
internationale un organisme créé par le
g7 souligne que les fiducie sont à haut
risque de servir ou crimes financiers
transparency international décrit les
fiducie comme la voiture de fuite d'un
cambriolage
le journal britannique the guardian
souligne le parallèle entre la blancheur
de nos hivers et la facilité d'utiliser
les fiducie au canada pour blanchir
défend pas accès à la véritable le
propriétaire réel donc ça facilite
markets
parce que vraiment on s'est vraiment
cliqué en arrière d'une telle compagnie
woods et l organisation et le
gouvernement canadien c'est que nous
avons des problèmes avec les fiducie
dans ce rapport le ministère des
finances donne une cote de risques très
élevés aux fiducie ce qui a donné lieu à
cette suggestion toute simple de marwa
risque ici dans les structures vous
voyez quel futur peut-être qu'il serait
sage à ce moment-là de refusé carrément
la licence puisque vous n'êtes pas en
mesure d'établir de façon non équivoque
que la cote de sécurité est vraiment
valette
[Musique]
le 5 juin les sénateurs sont de retour
pour débattre de la proposition du
sénateur carignan qui veut obliger plus
de transparence dans l'industrie du
cannabis réussira-t-il à faire adopter
son projet dans la raab le sénateur
carignan cp le bosseur acharné concerne
johnny cash et on le pousse à me
remettre à nantes
est ce que le gouvernement souhaite
réellement des contrôles qui empêche le
crime organisé d'entrer dans l'industrie
légale
on en parle tout se tapent à la pause
[Musique]
le canada a franchi un pas de plus vers
la légalisation du cannabis à des fins
récréatives
le projet de loi c 45 a été adopté ce
soir par les sénateurs en juin les
sénateurs ont voté sur l'amendement
proposé par le sénateur carignan
il visait à obliger les entreprises de
cannabis a donné beaucoup plus
d'informations sur leurs propriétaires
et investisseurs
et ça a reçu un accueil extrêmement
favorable de la part des sénateurs
libéraux de plusieurs sénateurs
indépendants ce qui fait que quand on a
passé au vote a été acceptée à avec un
appui à ce important
mais le suspense c'est vraiment de
savoir comment le gouvernement va réagir
à ces nombreux amendements il ya 46 à
quelques mois de la légalisation les
sénateurs ont envoyé la balle dans le
camp de justin trudeau
acceptera-t-il de demander plus de
transparence à l'industrie
dans le cadre de nos recherches nous
avons découvert que plusieurs individus
liés au monde criminel ont réussi à
entrer dans le marché légal dans une
entreprise on a exclu une personne au
passé criminel mais on a conclu une
entente avec lui pour lui verser
autrement une partie des profits de la
compagnie
un autre individu qui a plusieurs
trafiquants de drogue dans son entourage
a réussi à vendre son entreprise de
cannabis à l'un des grands joueurs de
l'industrie
il a reçu des actions de la compagnie et
lui loue ses installations à long terme
dans une troisième entreprise
deux des investisseurs au démarrage ont
eu des liens d'affaires avec le clan
rizutto rappelons que santé canada nous
a dit qu aucun cas d'infiltration par le
crime organisé n'a été constatée sur
plus de 100 producteurs autorisées
pourtant la grc lui on a signalé
plusieurs sources plus dans le passé
pour au niveau de marijuana pour des
fins médicales
si on regarde en 2016 et 2017 ses
semblables non au niveau des résultats
tandis qu'on se pose c'est ainsi
qu'alors il ya eu effectivement des
résultats positifs des résultats
positifs en termes policiers cela
signifie que la grc a soulevé des
drapeaux rouges pour plusieurs
demandeurs de permis
c'est vraiment des associations
criminelle une personne qui est associé
à des individus qui ont des casiers
judiciaires sur tout nouveau droit de
criminalité organisée
depuis des mois nous avons posé des
questions à santé canada sur son
processus sur sa façon de définir les
liens avec le crime organisé
malgré des demandes répétées aucun porte
parole n'était disponible pour une
entrevue par écrit santé canada affirme
qu'elle n'a délivré aucun permis dans
les cas où la grc lui a fourni la preuve
que des demandeurs étaient associés au
crime organisé
si sous l'ancien régime de cannabis à
des fins médicales que l'industrie s'est
vraiment développée pendant toute cette
période de 2013 à la légalisation en
vente libre cet automne santé canada ne
regardait que la première couche
corporative des demandeurs de permis
or plusieurs entreprises sont comme des
poupées russes une compagnie qui en
détient une autre avec parfois une
structure complexe et opaque comme nous
l'avons vu plus tôt mais santé canada
n'a pas regarder plus loin que la grosse
poupée le crime organisé est intelligent
il s'organise il s'adapte donc c'est
certain que c'est une personne qui a un
casier judiciaire c'est pour cette
personne là qu'ils vont mettre pour
demander la licence pour être
complètement naïf passer sa légère si
nous explique qu'elle fait de son mieux
mais que le volume de demandes est grand
et que les ressources sont limitées au
moment donné on peut pas avoir un
système complètement blindés 6k magazine
opportunités faire un profit
ils vont exploiter fait pas partie à une
grosse enquête pour chacun non une
grosse arnaque est absolument pas si je
vais pouvoir du nombre de demandes quand
je faisais qu'un grand nombre de
demandes que ce soit au niveau comme
j'ai besoin de vos cannabis au niveau
autres beaucoup de demandes
donc on pourrait être simplement pour se
permettre l'industrie du cannabis a
vertement critiqué le projet
d'amendement des sénateurs qui leur
demandaient davantage de transparence à
l'université d'ottawa
la criminologue line beauchesne qui
étudie la légalisation des drogues
depuis des décennies comprend la
position de l'industrie
je trouve que ce soit qui me dit qu'il
fait pour toutes les industries qui
s'installe au canada mais pourquoi par
ce client pour l'industrie du cannabis
elle souligne que le but des enquêtes et
des exigences de santé canada ce n'est
pas de combattre le blanchiment d'argent
mais d'offrir un cadre rassurant sur la
qualité des produits canadiens et
d'empêcher le marché noir
nous on peut se met à avoir 600
policiers s'en contente pour voir
monsieur pohlad d'un des dollars qui
proviennent de 2,6 ou de là nous on va
vous assurer que il y a pas de produits
de mauvaise qualité non contrôlés qui
proviennent de cette industrie le corps
médical canadienne ouzou alerter claude
carignan a gagné la bataille de rallier
ses collègues du sénat mais il a perdu
la guerre le gouvernement trudeau n'a
pas adopté la proposition le
gouvernement trudeau rejette 13 des
quarante six amendements soumis par le
sénat au projet loi sur la légalisation
du cannabis
tous les amendements majeurs ont été
rejetées par exemple celui qui visait à
créer un registre public d'investisseurs
dans l'industrie pour limiter
l'infiltration du crime organisé
gouvernement voyait trop grande
intrusion dans la vie privée des des
actionnaires
donc moi j'étais un peu déçu par cette
par cette réponse là et malheureusement
d'amendement est tombé
le gouvernement a cédé sur un point
important dans son nouveau règlement les
enquêtes iront plus en profondeur dans
les compagnies
on va ouvrir la poupée russe
mais jusqu'à un certain point et bien
après que l'industrie ne se soit très
bien développé claude carignan lui reste
déçu il croit que le crime organisé a
tout le loisir de s'implanter dans
l'industrie etc c'est probablement déjà
fait je pense que c'est trop facile
c'est trop facile de quelqu'un de
mauvaise foi qu utilisent l'outil
légitime d'une fiducie d'une compagnie
pour se cacher pour faire des activités
légitimes
on lui sert sur un plateau d'argent
c'est trop facile
santé canada aura beau dire qu aucune
infiltration du crime organisé n'a été
constatée dans l'industrie du cannabis
la réalité c'est que dans certains cas
le gouvernement ignore complètement
acquis il a vraiment donner des permis
[Musique]